I would say you could call it a religion
I don't particularly see it so much as a
religion but you could call it religion
it's more spirituality or even more
precisely it's a way of life it's a way
to be in the world to come from wisdom
to act with compassion and love and in
doing that to really be a kinder nicer
more empathetic compassionate person in
the world and it's less about rules and
it's less about dogma than it is about a
way to live one's life connected and
seeing the interconnectedness to all all
beings
no in fact I was raised agnostic by my
father and I was raised as an atheist by
my mother and I don't believe in a
particularly in an external God I
believed God but to me God is the same
as what I call big mind which is what
the title of my latest book is big mind
big heart it's also the title of the
work that I do big mind is when someone
allows themselves to identify with the
mind that has no boundaries no limits
has no beginning no end there's no birth
there's no death
that's the infinite that's the eternal
that's what we would call God it's the
absolute but I don't give it the name
usually as God although we can I just
call it big mind and big heart
big mind is obviously opening our mind
to the infinite just opening our
consciousness to the infinite again I
can use best the triangle so if the
left-hand side of the triangle is the
more restricted mind and heart the the
mind and heart that we encase and we
call that the self it's it's limited
it's finite its it's contained in in our
story who I think I am who I believe I
am you know what I would call Gimpo okay
that's the small mind all this in this
body what goes on here and in my
thoughts my beliefs my concepts my
opinions my ideas my notions about Who I
am okay that's the limited that's the
left-hand side on the other side big
mind is when you throw all that out when
you drop all that when you drop all the
concepts all the ideas all the notions
of who I am all the the story about it
and then I'm in that wonder in that
transcendent state where I just don't
know who I am I'm so big but there's no
one there to know there's no subject
object division there's no one there to
say oh I am this there's no here there's
no listener there's no seer I am all I
am the whole I am the infinite I am the
eternal that's big mind what we could
call the absolute or we could call God
big heart is the apex big heart is when
we combine or we include all the
personal the limit itself the small mind
the confined or limited mind and the big
mind out of the wisdom of big mind and
the conventional wisdom of the limited
self we moved to the apex and that's big
heart we open our heart up to its
limitless capacity its unconditional
love and caring it's unconditional
at this point my love for all sentient
beings my love for all inanimate is
animate for all all things and all
beings for the planet is so beyond
anything I can conceive of or imagine
because it's beyond imagination it's
beyond conception it's so open but
because it's balanced with big mind
because there's that balance I can care
infinitely I can compare I can care
without conditions unconditionally
that's big heart and then we take these
two into our daily life and we function
with wisdom and compassion that's a big
heart big mind
like all technologies spiritual
technologies we're advancing and for
2500 years what has eluded us in the
spiritual practice in the spiritual
world and then is also known as the
sudden school of Buddhism and it's
probably the most sudden and immediate
path most the pounds are more gradual
but Zen has always called itself the the
instant awaking the sudden awakening
that in one moment we can have a sudden
realization or sudden awaiting like
happened to me in February of 71 and
it's you know it's happened many many
times and to many spiritual practices
happen but what has eluded us is how do
you get someone to wake up so we have
something what's called a turning word
so if the student is really ripe kind of
like a chick in an egg and the chick is
really ready to be born the mother hen
will peck at that shell and crack it
open but if she cracks it too soon the
chick dies because the chick is not
fully developed but she cracks it too
late
the chick also will died so the mother
hen the timing is absolutely essential
so turning word is to pick on that shell
at just the right moment when the
student is ready to awaken and that's
always been an art it's always been
something that that a master has to be
totally tuned in to the disciple in
order to help them awaken and say just
the right thing so like one of those was
a monk came to the great master Joshua
and said there's a dog heaven Buddha
nature and Jo Xu just said mu and mu is
not the sound of a cow it was actually a
Chinese it was won't like that and the
student opened up the student awakened
another one was what is the meaning of
Bodhi Dharma bodhidharma was a great
master who came from india and brought
zen from our buddhism from India to
China and that became Zen so the
question is why did Bodhi Dharma come
from the West and joshua said the oak
tree in the garden and
that moment he was probably looking out
at this oak tree and the student looked
out at this oak tree and an opening had
an experience so we've been able to
bring students to a sudden realization
but it was never it was never that we
could determine the moment the the the
time in the place everything had to be
just right the the soil I would be just
prepared
what big mind the technology a big mind
is that we can do it with four hundred
people and an audience we can do it with
ten thousand people over the TV screen
or the computer screen we can do it with
millions of people and we can determine
when we do it because all it requires
and this is all requires is that the
person is prepared and wants to open up
and has just enough trust to follow the
directions so like this moment if I was
to say to you may I speak to big mind
please may I speak to big mind and then
as the listener says okay I am big mind
and then take a moment to just reflect
who you are I'm no longer Gimpo I'm no
longer Dennis Brasil now I am big mind
and then when we look in to our mind we
see as big mind I can find no birth no
beginning I can find no limit I find no
end I find no parameters no edges my
mind is infinite eternal and there's no
Gimpo there's no self and that is
technology because we've never been able
to do that before ten years ago almost
exactly it was ten years ago June then I
discovered big mind and since then
hundreds of thousands of people have
awakened either through workshops or
DVDs or the internet or YouTube with
this process the
cause the technology not only the
technical technology is there but the
spiritual technology is there because by
asking to speak to this voice once I
identify that I am it then all the
wisdom of the voice is there so I can
also ask to speak to the awakened mind
may I please speak to the awakened mind
and I say okay who are you
I'm the awakened mind well who are you
not well I'm not the non awakened mind
I'm not the unawakened mind I'm not the
mind that is deluded I am the waken mind
so what are you I'm awake does that mean
you're awake I'm awake I'm conscious
what do you cause you sir this what's
going on right here now what my
surroundings watching this interview I'm
awake well what's different now than
before well now I realize I'm awake I
didn't know I was awake before I am
awake what does that mean
oh my whole life just changed I am an
awakened to being what does that mean I
am a Buddha if we use those terms I'm an
awakened one when the Buddha was asked
who are you he said I'm sorry but that's
the wrong question so the questioner
said what's the right question the
correct question he said what are you so
if the person said well okay what are
you